well you seem like a very your character
is very emotional
yeah the movies he's very emotional is
very in touch with his emotions we're
both very open with open each other you
guys are more stoic tougher well
dysfunctional a little dysfunctional are
you you're an emotional guy in real life
would you say at interesting moments you
know not not necessarily the moments you
would think I get emotional watching
sports and watching movies on commercial
on airline flights for some reason I
feel very vulnerable in fact it was
trapped my wife and I were flying or and
and The Parent Trap was on not the
original but Lindsay Lohan's parents are
which it's still great it's still great
yeah I am sobbing like a baby at the end
when they and I know what's gonna happen
yeah but I'm still they got back
together they got the parents together
and I have tears streaming down my face
and my wife trans was like what is wrong
with you it's The Parent Trap so that's
an insight into my brain yeah
you